this is like a Picasso from afar it
looks right but then when you get up
close you're like whoa I'm Vaughn I'm a
tasty producer and I am here with my
lovely friends Ashley and essence who
are very inexperienced cooks can you
please put the knives down sharp things
on hands no no and today I'm going to be
challenging them to abate without a
recipe I literally just laid out
ingredients for them and they're gonna
have to figure out what to do with them
what we're gonna be making today ladies
is crusty brownies as my grandma would
call them she calls everybody ah I see
you have cookie dough Oreos and then
brownie mix what you have to do is you
have to figure out the order of those
layers and you need to figure out what
to mix with the brownie mix also how
long do make it for I actually have some
ingredients that aren't portioned out
correctly so you're gonna have to also
figure out the portions watch a tasty
recipe first no so there's no
instructions whatsoever do you need to
eat them at the end I do and so that's
the point
at the end I get to test your work it is
literally brownie batter and like
pre-made cookie dough how can you screw
it up
this yeah I don't even know what this is
oh is it the brownie mix yeah
got a nutmeg by the way if you think
you're up for the challenge
no okay I thought it was moldy pizza why
do we need sugar I thought they came to
our meeting done like I've imagined a
little devil yeah I don't know how to
make anything but I do know how to make
a box cake and you never add sugar
thanks awesome
we don't we need these too we don't need
all that oil in there dude
oh I bet it's wonderful okay that sounds
good for me but how do we measure this
out oh oh tablespoon okay Oh what
scuttling birds laughter at college
algebra twice just so you know you know
you know they offered algebra oh you're
saying you took it twice like you were
so good you wanted to take it yeah I
think it's so bad right look at me now
you don't need master beautif a
Bueller's a bit I'm really glad side
note that I didn't make y'all make
macarons because that was gonna be the
original we would have literally been
here for days okay that's it that's 1/4
oh I'm making a mess hmm this is looking
kind of shanky should we put all the oil
maybe I like a drop a drop I like to
have a lot of oil in my diet I'm dry
skin right beauty editor yeah it's good
we did it right oh that's weird
no we need a brush we're painting with
butter do we need a little more just to
make sure it doesn't stay it's a nick
it's what this is a nonstick okay let's
talk about density this is probably the
heaviest second heaviest slightest I
think these need to go first
and then these and then this or is it
these this and this bond has the most
expressive face ever so I'm just trying
to say things and like look over at the
right time he really can't hide anything
my initial instinct is cookie dough
because that's dense and it's heavy so
it'll stay at the bottom then needs and
then this so you got a little brownie
and each bite okay so are we doing these
now yeah this is my heart I'm here then
chewy Michael no do we just have to play
with these with their hands
okay I think this looks good okay yeah
good job it's all ready so now we're
going to layer the Oreos great cookie
dough with Oreos are these solid are
crushed what are you thinking I'm
picturing like beautifully laid almost
like you know how Khloe Kardashian lays
her cookies in those cookie jars and
like a waste of time yeah for BuzzFeed
video listen I know what Pinterest
dessert when I see well then that looks
like it just call me Vanna black hahaha
this is really crazy ready okay what if
we do one layer like this and then we do
one layer smashed okay and we can just
stick it in here and just let out our
aggression and smash them on the table
headphone users beware she's a little
more gentle than me I like this little
remix for doing like grouch you know
these are our tiles oh oh this smells
good it smells really good
should we add a little butter I like
butter thing just a little it's gonna
bake right it looks like caramel I know
it's heavy I feel good actually I'm
really confident in this I think this is
about three the best [ __ ] brownie
you've seen this side of the Statue of
Liberty now y'all have to figure out how
long to bake them then oh my god how
long do you normally bake their box cake
until they stick a fork in it and it's
not like so maybe we should do that but
how do we tell if the bottoms cooks we
can't even see it because when we stick
it all the way in there we're gonna pull
it back yeah fingers crossed
[Music]
okay it has a couple of craters I like
when brownies have a crack in the top
okay okay so that's a win it might be
from the
that uterus ah just a little hole it
smells really good it looks moist bad
enough that means you know cook oh yeah
oh right yeah I'm like let's dig in or
if you got we have to test it ah it's
not going oh shoot it looks like oh no
no what there's 12 the chips that's what
that is
okay please hold the knife down and then
you always announce in the kitchen when
you have something sharp and when you're
behind the sympathy sharp behind no one
who doesn't cook wouldn't know what that
meant
oh you got to be like girl watch that I
got a nice that looks like it's got a
nice crunch on the top and bouncing it
look at the butter oh it's not good that
is not good it's not good medium rare
Cheers there's a really sweet this is so
close to being hurt I can't imagine if
we had left it in longer how the middle
would have gotten cooked there were a
couple things that went wrong you were
supposed to put the butter in the
brownie batter too and less oil in the
brownie batter uh we went for it with
the oil yeah I mean it's gooey
like the middle of what temperature did
y'all set it at I don't know I just put
it in there I think it was in there too
high of a temperature with something
that's such high volume it should have
probably been low and slow so that you
has time to cook on the god I mean all
in all for to non cooks with no recipe
this is impressive
Wow I'm shocked that I think I like it
less than one it's really sweet it needs
salt on top what about the Oreos
what's the ground Oreo correct
the full wheel I would have done full
Oreo but you were good to break the Oreo
and like kind of fit it in the cracks I
feel accomplished and very proud of this
because we don't cook we had no recipe
and it's taste good to me like it's
edible I'm proud of it
edible is good
[Music]